[Music]
these are images many people in somalia
don't want to see
a political and security crisis is
threatening to destabilize the country
once again
and our security forces are taking sides
these soldiers arrived in the capital
mogadishu from front line positions in
here shabbale
in the south recalled by their sector
commander who is opposed to the
extension of president muhammad abdullah
if our major
in office by another two years they went
to the streets in protest
alongside some city residents
they fought with police forces loyal to
present for major several times
most of the people are in defiance of
the government extending term limits
the president whose term has finished
could lead the country into war
a peaceful demonstration is underway
here now and the military are capturing
new positions
the country could be taken back into
civil war
last week a police commander who was
fired for trying to stop parliament
from debating the presidential time
limits retreated to his home in a
residential area of mogadishu
with forces loyal to him analysts say
the security crisis is likely to
embolden ultrabook fighters
to take control of areas that might be
abandoned by military forces
and step up their talks this is actually
a dangerous decision
that has triggered all of these problems
but the root cause
is that every four year somalia often
has
some sort of a rotation of power that
hasn't happened
under the leadership of the president
parliament recently voted to extend the
time of the president
and his government after it expired in
february
and talks to organize another election
have stalled after leaders failed to
agree on the process
the president is under pressure to step
down but he accuses some leaders from
regional states
of making things difficult and some
countries like kenyan djibouti
of interfering with somalia's political
affairs the president
needs to de-escalate this uh this
conflict and go back to the
to the negotiations with the federal
member states and the opposition leaders
there is no other way out that i can see
president famado has tried
to get support from international
partners including the african union
with little
success now he appears to be
increasingly isolated
but he and his supporters are standing
their ground saying somali is a
sovereign country
and the presidential time extension was
necessary to avoid a political vacuum
catherine soy al jazeera